quel seul loire voit sa grande gueule
[Musique]
qui est intéressant à propos de cette
fanfaronnade 7 jactance de ces injures
[Musique]
c'est que même et à leeds à un moment
donné je les ai observés çà m'a touché
ce que tout le monde ignore c'est avant
de monter sur le ring je meurs de peur
je pourrais ce que cela ne serait pas
une manière d'exorciser la peur et de la
vaincre je serais content que je posais
tout à l'heure d'ailleurs courage et
l'adversaire je suis prête à répondre à
la question le sait cette tornade gêne
les blancs plus que les noirs parce que
pour les noirs je peux assurer que cela
donne le sentiment de confiance parce
que n'oubliez pas que nous sommes nous
sommes les inférieur et eux sont fiers
de devoir précisément à de leurs frères
en train de dire aux gens ce qu'il a à
leur dire parce que bon à paris en
angleterre en amérique par tous les
noirs ont l'impression d'être traités
comme des animaux
alors c'est une revanche pour eux quand
ils me voient
c'est une inspiration pour eux vous bon
vous vous n'aimez pas beaucoup ce genre
de fanfaronnade parce que vous vous
dites qu'elle est ce noir qu'elle se loi
ouvre sa grande gueule
non nous ne nous lui avons jamais appris
à se comporter de la sorte nous nous
avons fait des esclaves des gens comme
ça nous n'avons jamais appris à ces
gens-là d'être fiers
non parce que le mal est tous les
modèles tous les mannequins sont des
femmes blanches on le sait bien et
jésus-christ tout le monde tout le monde
et plan tout était blanc alors quel est
ce noir qui subitement se permettent
d'ouvrir sa grande gueule pour dire
qu'il est le plus grand alors ça ça vous
gêne
[Musique]